what happens when 800 of the world's
most elite footballers and their
managers live together under one roof
players stop being polite and start
getting real this is the champion some
say I'm the best in the world I agree
with them I'm lean and messy I let my
football speak for itself
[Music]
Kevin people said I couldn't carry Egypt
they were arrived
[Music]
[Music]
so today is a rival day and I'm going to
be meeting my new who Ventus teammates
it's hard because in Italy they are very
focused on image it's like all about
their looks their hair their tan it's
all very new to me and trying to connect
to the average Italian so I bought that
typical Italian car somewhat traditional
Italian clothing and I've been reading
up on local politics what's good my man
happiest day of my life when my son was
born reading my feet bell on door okay
so I like the colors but I would make
one quick change of course it is we get
fatter than you guys this isn't about
what country you're from just about psg
me just about paris dis about Ron's baby
yeah oh look everybody and Bobby brought
the world of the prodigy so good so
y'all don't eat all its money to charity
Bobby yeah me yeah
so you went woke up he's good still
doesn't want to push goes
there's still little water the wool okay
bro man's got jokes eh I do if jokes in
fact ago hold a nerdy story English
Rachel Ritalin so I thought it'd take
some of them three lines to go slaughter
Gordon's little English London time you
know come along lad so lead the way what
you said you could take us home oh no I
can't I can't it's right there we we
just need to get over that off
semi-final I mean either Hill
what an [ __ ] is pressure
well I swear on the grave dig with it I
gave it me oh I traded all the golden
boat send me beats in only time for one
more chance imagine of running final Oh
Harry I'm so sorry my it's just none of
us have any idea what you just said
[Music]